Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Bei Hannover 96 gab es mal wieder ein paar neue Entwicklungen und wie er das schon vom Rasenfunk kennt, begleiten wir diese Entwicklung natürlich. Heute mit Dr. Andreas Hüttl hier im Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Andreas, sei mir sehr herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk. Hallo.
Grüß dich, Max. Freue mich, dabei zu sein.
Erklär doch mal unseren Hörern und Hörern, welchen Bezug hast du denn zu Hannover 96?
Ich bin lange Zeit Fan über 30 Jahre, bei 35 Jahren Fan von Hannover 96, bin lange Jahre Mitglied von Hannover 96, habe mit den Vereinen gestritten, gegen den Vereinen gestritten, für den Verein gestritten, war in der Satzungskommission von Hannover 96, war selbst mal Aufsichtsratskandidat und wir haben den Fanbeirat gemeinsam eingerichtet. Also ich habe mit Hannover einfach auch viel zu tun.
Ja, das merkt man und deswegen bist du auch genau der Richtige mit uns, jetzt über die jüngsten Entwicklungen zu sprechen. Es wurde unter anderem ein neuer Aufsichtsrat im e.V. gewählt. Weil aber Hannover 96 durchaus ein nicht ganz so unterkomplexes Gebilde ist, würde ich gerne mal vorne anfangen. Kannst du uns nochmal kurz erklären, wie kamen denn eigentlich Martin Kind und Hannover 96 zusammen?
Etwas über 20 Jahre her, 1997, ist Martin Kind Präsident geworden von Hannover 96. Dem Verein ging es damals einigermaßen schlecht. Man spielte in der dritten Liga, wirtschaftlich war es auch alles nicht gold. Ob nun wirklich, wie Herr Kind es oft gesagt hat, der Tatbestand der Insolvenz damals vollumfänglich vorgelegen hat, oder wie er es damals gesagt hat, dass es jedenfalls kritisch war, aber die Insolvenz nicht vor der Tür stand, da scheinen sich so ein bisschen die Geister. Aber man kann wohl sagen, insgesamt ging es dem Verein einfach nicht so gut. Martin Kind ist auf eine außerordentliche Mitgliedersammlung im Jahr 97 Präsident geworden und hat dann relativ schnell versucht, beziehungsweise es auf den Weg gebracht, dass die Profi-Abteilung ausgegliedert wurde. Also die Umstände, die jetzt bei Köln oder bei Stuttgart im Moment aktuell sind, die gab es bei Hannover schon vor knapp 20 Jahren. Es ist dann ausgegliedert worden in die KGAA. Und seitdem war Herr Kind in der Personalunion sozusagen Präsident des e.V. und gleichzeitig Geschäftsführer der KGAA. Also er hatte alle Fäden, liefen bei ihm zusammen.
Und was war damals die Begründung, also weil vor 20 Jahren eine KGAA auszuründen, das war ja damals noch was anderes als heute, wo das dann immer mit möglichen Investoren und man müsse das tun, um sich zu professionalisieren, verargumentiert wird. Was waren denn damals die Gründe dafür?
Na ja, damals, was er damals auf der Mitgliederversammlung, wo das beschlossen wurde, als Begründung angegeben hat, dass eben darüber frisches Kapital wieder in den Club kommt, sozusagen. Also die Argumente waren eigentlich mehr oder weniger die gleichen. Ich weiß nicht, ob er jetzt wirklich Vorreiter gewesen ist oder ob andere damals auch schon ausgegliedert hatten. Aber die Begründung war, frisches Kapital von Geldgebern aus seinem bekannten Schrägstrich-Freundes-Unternehmer-Kreis auch an Hannover zu binden. Und dem musste man ja auch irgendwas bieten sozusagen für Engagement. Und das waren die Anteile an dem e.V. Er hat damals aber auch gesagt, dass zwar ausgeliedert werden sollte, aber dass der Verein immer das letzte Wort haben soll, dass 50 plus 1 auf jeden Fall zu wahren ist. Da ist dann im Laufe der Zeit nicht mehr viel von über geblieben. Aber so ist es damals angekündigt und auch mit großer Mehrheit der Mitglieder damals so beschlossen worden.
Aber so ganz passt das ja auch in der Rückschau nicht zusammen. Vielleicht hat sich das damals anders angefühlt, weil die sportliche Lage ja auch tatsächlich nicht so rosig war. Wir sprechen da ja auch nur nicht von Erstliga-Fußball bei Hannover 96. Aber ich muss ja möglichen Investoren was bieten. Und das sind ja zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder Gewinne, schwierig, wenn es gerade nicht so läuft bei Hannover 96. Das andere ist Mitbestimmung und dann eben Gestaltungswillen. Und dann muss es ja eigentlich dieser zweite Grund gewesen sein.
Ja, also Gewinne, ich glaube nicht, dass wirklich Gewinne nach Wirtschaften wurden dazwischen. Jetzt streiten sich im Moment die Gesellschafter untereinander, ob Gewinne die Überschüsse, die angefallen sind, ob die nun ausgezahlt werden oder in der Gesellschaft verbleiben sollen. Da gibt es auch Rechtsstreitigkeiten zwischen den Gesellschaftern, die kürzlich beendet worden sind. Also ob die Vorgabe, Gewinne zu erzielen, da wirklich so eine große Rolle gespielt hat, das kann ich tatsächlich für die einzelnen Gesellschaften natürlich nicht beurteilen. Da stecke ich nicht drin. Aber auch ein Stück weit die Präsentation ist natürlich auch ganz wichtig, also ohne dispiktierlich wirken zu wollten. Aber wer kannte vor 20 Jahren Martin Kind und Kind Hörgeräte? Da ist natürlich auch neben dem Platz sozusagen ein erheblicher Imagegewinn daraus entstanden. Und ja, das war möglicherweise auch ein Grund mit dafür.
Ja, okay, gut. Und das würde dann natürlich auch begründen, weil meine Frage zieht ein bisschen darauf hin, wenn man Gewinne ausschließt als das entscheidende Kriterium, warum Investoren ihr Geld geben sollten und gleichzeitig aber an 50 plus 1 festhalten möchte, dann kann ja dieser Gestaltungswille auch nicht das eigentliche Argument gewesen sein. Aber dann ist es vielleicht eine Mixtur und dieser Imagegewinn und die Möglichkeit, eben auch was für einen Verein zu machen, den man ja vermutlich dann auch persönlich gar nicht so doof findet. Das könnte dann ja eine ganz gute Argumentation gewesen sein.
Ja, das will ich auch nicht ausschließen, dass das natürlich auch aus dem Willen heraus etwas für den Verein zu tun entschieden wurde. Also da will ich ein Kind auch tatsächlich nicht zu schlecht reden, was seine ursprünglichen Motive anbelangte jedenfalls.
Und das war jetzt alles im Jahr 1996. Das heißt, seitdem gibt es die Hannover 96 GmbH und Co-KGAA. Da musst du schon lachen.
Ja, da muss ich schon lachen. Also Kind ist seit 1997 Präsident und die Ausliederung war dann 1998 in die Hannover 96 GmbH und Co-KGAA. Genau so ist es richtig.
Und seitdem hat sich ja aber noch mal ein bisschen mehr verändert. Also wenn ich mir heute die Vereinstruktur auf der offiziellen Vereinsseite angucke, dann sehe ich da zwar noch den e.V., aber ich sehe auch noch eine Management GmbH, ich sehe eine Sales und Service GmbH und Co-KGAA, eine gut Arena GmbH und Co-KGAA, das ist jetzt nicht so außergewöhnlich heutzutage im Fußball und noch die Primetec GmbH, mit der ich jetzt gar nichts anfangen kann. Kannst du mir das kurz erklären?
Ja, also die Primetec GmbH ist das letztliche Sicherheitsdienst sozusagen, der eben teilweise mit einem Sicherheitsdienst in Hannover, mit der Pro-Tech, gemeinsam geschaffen wurde, damit man sozusagen auch für die Stadion Sicherheit in einer Regie zuständig sein kann. Das kann man tatsächlich ein Stück weit vernachlässigen für das Konstrukt Hannover 96. Die Management GmbH, das ist jetzt sozusagen das Entscheidende, worauf sich im Ergebnis der Streit kapriziert hat. Also in dem Konstrukt KGAA ist die Management GmbH sozusagen diejenige, die den Geschäftsführer der KGAA, also den Geschäftsführer der Profiabteilung bestimmt. Die wiederum ist im hundertprozentigen Besitz vom Hannover 96 e.V. Es ist nachdem die ersten Anteile verkauft worden sind, so gewesen, dass die Gesellschafter ständig regelmäßig Kapitalerhöhungen vorgenommen haben, sodass der proportionale Anteil der Gesellschaftsanteile des e.V.s immer weniger wurde. Und im Jahr 2014 bei der Mitgliederversammlung ist dann mitgeteilt worden, dass auch die letzten Anteile, die der e.V. noch gehalten hat, damals waren es 15 Prozent, der Rest ist über die Kapitalerhöhungen weggefressen worden, die letzten 15 Prozent dann verkauft worden sind. Also es ist den Mitgliedern nicht sozusagen vorgestellt worden, wir wollen gerne verkaufen, was heißt das davon, sondern es ist schlicht mitgeteilt worden, der Verkauf hat stattgefunden. Und in dem Moment hatte Herr Kind bzw. Herr Kind und seine Investorengruppe alle Anteile des e.Vs übernommen, sodass man sich sehr wohl die Frage stellen könnte, naja, aber wenn der Verein gar keine Anteile mehr hat, wie um alles in der Welt soll denn 50 plus 1 erfüllt sein. Das ist eben darüber konstruiert, dass über die Bestimmung des Geschäftsführers der KGH über die Management GmbH, die dem e.V. gehört, der direkte Einfluss da eben doch möglich ist. Also der e.V. könnte theoretisch den Geschäftsführer der KGH ablösen und jemand anderes dort einsetzen. Und da sagt die DFL, ja, das reicht uns, ich sag mal Klammer auf, gerade noch so, 50 plus 1 erfüllt anzusehen. Es soll Rechtsgutachten geben, auch bei der DFL, die das schon um das Jahr 2009 hin sehr kritisch gesehen haben. Das ist aber nur sozusagen bei mir vom Hören sagen Kenntnis. Ich hab diese Gutachten nicht gesehen oder irgendwas, aber es soll so sein. Man kann das sehr wohl schon grundsätzlich kritisch sehen, aber über dieses Bestimmungsrecht Geschäftsführer, dort ist eben 50 plus 1 offiziell noch geregelt. Und eben gerade diese Management GmbH, die möchte Herr Kind nun kaufen, dass er sozusagen alle Anteile hat und auch das Recht den Geschäftsführer zu bestellen. Und das wäre dann eben das Zerschneiden des letzten Bandes zwischen Profi-Fußball und e.V. Und das ist das, was eben vielen Mitgliedern hier ja einigermaßen übel aufstößt.
Also ich versuche das noch mal kurz aufzudröseln, damit auch jede Hörer und jede Hörerin da die Chance hat mitzukommen. Wir haben zum einen den e.V. Da sind alle Sportabteilungen drin, außer die Profi-Fußballabteilung. Die wurde ausbegliedert in die KGAA. Und die KGAA wird aus der Management GmbH, die quasi zwischen beiden steht. Da bestimmt sich der Geschäftsführer heraus und über der Management GmbH steht eigentlich der e.V., der eben den Geschäftsführer bestimmen kann. Und das heißt, und dann hast du jetzt eben quasi gerade uns erklärt, bei der KGAA, da sind schon alle Anteile in Händen von, ich sage jetzt einfach mal, private Personen, nicht mehr in Händen des e.V.s. Und das Ziel von Martin Kind war jetzt auch in der Management GmbH, also quasi in dem dazwischen geschalteten Konstrukt, auch noch das alleinige Bestimmungsrecht zu haben. Und dann ging ja tatsächlich so ein bisschen die Entscheidungsgewalt vom e.V., die ja eh nur noch in der Person des Geschäftsführers vorhanden ist, wo ich mir schon die Frage stelle, wie viel kann er dann eigentlich noch wirklich entscheiden. Das ginge dann auch noch verloren. Und darum ging es jetzt dann auch in der jüngsten Mitgliederversammlung. Die Mitgliederversammlung sind bei euch ja immer relativ spektakulär. Also da bekommt man viel mit. Auch deswegen wird das hier im Rasenfunk unter anderem begleitet. Unterscheiden sich denn auch eure Mitgliederversammlung von den anderen Vereinen? Oder was ist da immer los bei 96?
Ja, muss man auch wieder ein bisschen historisch begründen sozusagen. Also wie gesagt, die Anteile wurden durch Kapitalerhöhungen sozusagen eingesungen. Und der Kind hat dann tatsächlich so ab Jahr 2010, 2011 schon einen Kund getan, dass er gerne die absolute Macht übernehmen möchte und dass er meint, dass 50 plus 1 insgesamt eine rechtswidige Regelung ist. Ich verkürze das mal ein bisschen. Es gab dann schon damals ein Schiedsgerichtsverfahren, wo dann ein Vergleich in Anlehnung auf Leverkusen und Wolfsburg geschlossen wurde, dass derjenige, der sich eben 20 Jahre erheblich und ständig für einen Verein engagiert, dass derjenige die Möglichkeit haben kann, die gesamte Macht zu übernehmen. Das ist das, was man sich als Hannover-Fan, als Hannover 96-Mitglied ein Stück weit angreiden muss, dass man in diesen Jahren 2010, 2011 dann noch nicht verbindlich und richtig darauf reagiert hat. Das hing zum damaligen Zeitpunkt natürlich auch ein großes Stück weit mit dem sportlichen Erfolg damals zusammen. 2010, 2011, 2012 wirklich gute Saisons gespielt, europäisch, Europapokal gespielt. Und da ging das so ein bisschen unter, dass Herr Kind damals schon offen gesagt hat, ich will das alles übernehmen. Da kehrte wieder ein bisschen Ruhe ein, nachdem dieser Vergleich geschlossen wurde beim Schiedsgericht. Und erst als dann im Jahr 2014, 2015 mitgeteilt wurde, dass die Anteile jetzt endgültig verkauft worden sind, da fing es an, sich Widerstand sozusagen auch zu organisieren. Noch ein Jahr zurück, im Jahr 2014 waren bei der Mitgliederversammlung 200 Personen, also 200 Mitglieder im Jahr 2014. Das hat nicht wirklich interessiert sozusagen. Und das steigerte sich dann immer über die Jahre in so zwei, dreihunderter Schritten bis eben dieses Jahr tatsächlich über 2000 stimmberechtigte Mitglieder bei der Mitgliederversammlung gewesen sind, von insgesamt 7000 stimmberechtigten Mitgliedern. Also wirklich gut über ein Drittel. Das war schon, das steigerte sich immer. Und es war auch tatsächlich immer relativ viel los. Wie gesagt, 2015 wurde gesagt, wir haben die Anteile verkauft, nur dass man da auch ein paar Zahlen hat. Die letzten 15 Prozent der Gesellschaftsanteile wurden für 3,6 Millionen Euro verkauft. Herr Kind hatte einen Gutachten erstellen lassen und das Gutachten kam zu dem Ergebnis, dass sei der korrekte Kaufpreis. Also 15 Prozent von einem Bundesligisten für 3,6 Millionen, wenn du das hochrechnest, dann war Hannover 96 tatsächlich insgesamt billiger Jakob. Und auch der Kauf dieser Management GmbH, der ja wirklich sozusagen dann das entscheidende Kriterium war, sollte eben für den Nominalwert dieser GmbH 250.000, 51 Prozent davon, 12.750 Euro nur einbringen. Und wenn man sich überlegt, was da doch für eine Machtfülle dann entsteht und dass das unumkehrbar ist und du als e.V. dann 12.750 Euro dafür bekommst, das war hier jedenfalls ein Stück weit unverständlich. Die Mitgliederversammlung 2016, da waren dann schon, da waren auch Aufsichtsratswahlen, das war vor drei Jahren, alle drei Jahre sind Aufsichtsratswahlen. Da hatte sich der, ich nenne es jetzt mal die Opposition oder der Widerstand schon ein bisschen besser organisiert, war aber noch, ja, muss man auch erkennen, in sich vielleicht nicht ganz einig. Ich war damals auch Kandidat, da gab es ein Stück weit Differenzen, man wurde sich nicht ganz einig und am Ende des Tages sind zwei, sage ich mal, Mitglieder, die eher der Opposition zuzurechnen sind, jedenfalls diese Übernahmepläne eigentlich abgelehnt haben, in den Aufsichtsrat berufen worden. Dann fing das langsam an, dass man ein bisschen mehr Einblick auch bekam. Dann sind im Jahr 2017 versucht worden, einen Satzungsänderungsantrag in der Mitgliederversammlung durchgehen zu lassen, dass die Satzung eben festschreiben sollte, dass diese Management GmbH unverkäuflich sei. Also dass dieses Wandel zwischen e.V. und Kapitalgesellschaft eben auf alle Zeit nicht durchtrennt werden kann. Zum Beispiel Borussia Dortmund hat eine entsprechende Regelung in der Satzung. Das wäre eine Möglichkeit gewesen, diesen 50 plus 1 Zustand festzuschreiben. Dieser Satzungsendungsantrag hat knapp die notwendige Zweidrittelmehrheit nicht erreicht. Aber auch da schon ganz deutlich der überwiegende Teil, also weit über 60 Prozent der Mitglieder, 66 Prozent, 66,6 Prozent hätte man gebraucht. Über 60 Prozent der Mitglieder haben damals schon gesagt, wir wollen das so in die Satzung geschrieben haben, dass diese Trennung eben nicht vorgenommen wird. Wie gesagt, hat nicht ganz gereicht. Es gab einen weiteren Antrag im Jahr 2017, der da hingerichtet war, sinngemäß, naja, also wenn du, lieber Hannover 96 e.V., das verkaufen möchtest, dann bitte vorher eine außerordentliche Mitgliederversammlung, wo uns sozusagen das Kaufangebot vorgestellt wird, wo wir die wirtschaftlichen Daten nachvollziehen können. Und dann möchten wir darüber abstimmen, ob wir diesem Verkauf zustimmen oder nicht.
Damit es nicht so läuft wie damals bei der KGAA, wo man einfach vor vollendete Tatsachen gestellt hat.
Ganz genau, das war sozusagen die Erfahrung aus dem Jahr 2015, wo die Anteilsverkäufe einfach gemacht worden sind. Und dieser Antrag in der Mitgliederversammlung 2017, der ist mit knapp 80 Prozent angenommen worden. Also knapp 80 Prozent der Mitglieder in der Mitgliederversammlung damals haben gesagt, okay, wir sagen gar nicht nein grundsätzlich, aber wenn du das machen willst, lieber Herr Kind, dann bitte frag uns vorher und stell uns dein Konzept vor und erzähl uns, wie das alles auch finanziell läuft. Diese 80 Prozent, die dafür gestimmt haben, der entsprechende Beschluss der Mitgliederversammlung wurde von Herrn Kind als Empfehlung dargestellt. Also er hat sich da nicht drangehalten und hat dann gleichwohl den Ausnahmeantrag gestellt, damit er eben diese Management je mehr kaufen kann.
Und darum ging es jetzt dann in der aktuellen Versammlung? Oder kommt da jetzt auch noch die Aussichtsratswahl mit zusammen? Also ich habe noch im Kopf und die Hörerinnen und Hörer vielleicht auch, dass es eigentlich schon im Herbst oder Ende des Herbstes, im Winter, eine Versammlung hätte geben sollen und dass das jetzt quasi Termin Nummer zwei ist, den nicht alle unbedingt haben wollten. Kannst du mir das nochmal kurz erklären?
Ja, also es ist ja so, dass der Antrag, den Herr Kind dann gestellt hat, also gegen die ausdrückliche Votum der Mitgliederversammlung hat er den Antrag gestellt, dass der von der DFL abgelehnt wurde, weil die DFL nach Prüfung, der von Herrn Kind eingereichten Unterlagen befunden hat, dass eben keine über 20 Jahre andauernde erhebliche Förderung vorgelegen hat. Um jetzt auch hier wieder ein paar Zahlen ins Spiel zu bringen, die Regularien der DFL sehen eben vor, dass die Zuwendung, die Förderung, die der mit zehn Investoren, wie immer man ihn nennen will, gegeben hat, dem e.V. die gleiche Höhe haben muss, wie der jeweilige Hauptsponsor. Also man muss gucken, wie viele Hauptsponsoren Einnahmen hat 96 über diese 20 Jahre gehabt, wie viel hat Herr Kind gefördert und da hat eben die DFL gesagt, liebe Herr Kind, der Umfang, in dem du gefördert hast, ist nicht ausreichend, dass wir dir Ausnahmegenehmigung geben. Dagegen ist Herr Kind dann wieder vor das ständige Schiedsgericht gezogen und als diese Situation so sehr unklar war, wird nun zu seinen Gunsten entschieden oder wird gegen ihn entschieden, da meinten einige Mitglieder, es sei eine gute Idee, in einer außerordentlichen Mitgliederversammlung diejenigen Aufsichtsräte abzuwählen, die damals für diesen Antrag gestimmt haben. Dieser Antrag auf Ausnahmegenehmigung bei DFL muss von drei Personen bzw. von drei Rechtsobjekten gestellt werden, nämlich von dem Übernehmer selbst, das ist Martin Kind, von dem Spielbetriebsveranstalter, das ist die KGH, und von dem abgebenden Verein. Also der abgebende Verein, Hannover 96 e.V., hat diesem Antrag auch zugestimmt, mit der Mehrheit von damals drei Aufsichtsräten, die Herrn Kind zuzurechnen sind. Das Pikante dabei ist, dass die Antragsunterlagen, also die Zahlen, die den Antrag gestützt haben, dem Aufsichtsrat gar nicht vorgelegt wurden. Und das war ein großer Kritikpunkt der beiden Aufsichtsräte, die in dem Jahr zuvor gewählt worden sind. Die haben gesagt, wir können noch als Aufsichtsrat, also unsere Verpflichtung ist es, den Vorstand zu kontrollieren. Und wie sollen wir denn dieses Kontrollrecht anständig wahrnehmen, wenn wir gar nicht wissen, mit welchen Zahlen der Vorstand da jongliert? Und deswegen hat man gesagt, eine außerordentliche Mitgliederversammlung um die drei Aufsichtsräte, die das gestützt haben, ohne Kenntnis der Inhalte dieses Antrages abzuwählen. Dafür braucht man nach der Satzung von 96 ein Quorum von 5 Prozent der Mitglieder, die dieses Begehren auf außerordentliche Mitgliederversammlung stützen müssen. Die Zahl hatte man dann erreicht, hatte den Antrag auch eingereicht. Der Vorstand hat aber auch gesagt, wir machen das nicht. Es ist zu teuer, es ist zu nah an der nächsten ordentlichen Mitgliederversammlung. Das wollen wir nicht. Da gab es Rechtsstreitigkeiten, das ist jetzt aber alles Historie. Jedenfalls ist es nicht gemacht worden. Und so kam es jetzt im Jahr 2019 dann tatsächlich erneut zur Aufsichtsratswahl, die turnusmäßig alle drei Jahre durchzuführen ist. Und bei dieser mittleren Versammlung zur Aufsichtsratswahl haben sich eben sozusagen zwei Teams gebildet. Einmal fünf Kandidaten, die eher dem Lager, um Martin Kind zuzurechnen, sind. Es gab noch einen unabhängigen Kandidaten, der …Dann sind es auch elf, das passt auch zum Fußball. Ja genau, elf Freunde sollte es sein. Elf Aufsichtsratskandidaten. Das ist auf der einen Seite wirklich eine ganz tolle Sache gewesen, weil du jetzt wirklich eine Auswahl hattest. Also über lange Jahre, die ich das begleitet habe, waren immer fünf Kandidaten, die wurden alle gewählt. Das wurde so durchgewunken und diesmal hatte man halt tatsächlich eine wirkliche Auswahl. Die Teams sozusagen, die ihre Programme ja auch vorgestellt haben über alle möglichen Kanäle, die waren sich eigentlich in weiten Teilen, hatten die ähnliche Ziele. Also alle wollten den breiten Sport fördern, alle wollten Gräben zuschütten, alle wollten aufeinander zugehen. Also ich sag mal, das ganze Allgemeine drum herum war eigentlich relativ gleich. Im Kern war die Abkretzung sozusagen, dass die in Anführungszeichen kindfreundlichen Aufsichtsratkandidaten gesagt haben, der Plan, den Martin Kind bisher verfolgt hat, nämlich die gesamte Macht zu übernehmen, den Ausnahmeantrag bei DFL zu stellen und das Bann zwischen Profiabteilung und e.V. zu trennen, das ist eine gute Sache. Wenn wir Aufsichtsrat wären, würden wir das weiter so stützen und mittragen, während die Kandidaten, die eher der Opposition zuzurechnen sind, gesagt haben, das geht so nicht, weil wir haben einen Mitgliederbeschluss aus dem Jahr 2017, knapp 80%, die gesagt haben, ja, möglicherweise kannst du einen Antrag stellen, aber wir wollen informiert und mit gutem Gewissen sozusagen in einer Mitgliederversammlung darüber hinstellen. Und das war das Ziel der anderen Kandidaten, die sich dort zur Wahl gestellt haben. Und das lief dann eben auf diese Mitgliederversammlung dieses Jahr am 23. letzten Samstag zu, wo dann eben diese beiden Lager aufeinander getroffen sind. Und es war die größte Mitgliederversammlung in der Geschichte von Hannover 96, also selbst wie gesagt, damals die Ausliederungsmitgliederversammlung und da waren nie so viele Leute. Es war die größte Mitgliederversammlung und alle Kandidaten hatten Gelegenheit, ihre Konzepte vorzustellen und dann wurde abgestimmt.
Und es wurde ein 0 zu 5 aus Sicht der Kandidaten, die Martin Kind unterstützen wollten und gesagt, hätten ja diesen Antrag, den unterstützen wir weiter. Das heißt, nur Vertreter aus der sogenannten Opposition wurden jetzt in den Aufsichtsrat gewählt, mit dem Ex-Profikasten Linke, Lasse Gutsch, Natalie Wartmann, Ralf Nestler und Jens Beuth. Was heißt es dann jetzt? Können die diesen einmal gestellten Ausnahmeantrag jetzt dann zurücknehmen? Jetzt wäre es ja wahrscheinlich ein 5 zu 0, wenn man nochmal drüber aufstimmen würde im Aufsichtsrat. Was wird jetzt passieren?
Na ja, also von der Satzung her ist es so, der Aufsichtsrat wird in der Mitgliederversammlung von den Mitgliedern gewählt und der Aufsichtsrat bestimmt dann den Vorstand, den Vorstandsvorsitzenden des e.V., also beide Aufsichtsratlager, sage ich mal, hatten sich einen Kandidaten, ja, ausgesucht, mit denen zusammengearbeitet, also sowohl das Team Kind als auch Team Opposition hatten jeweils einen, eine Person, wo sie gesagt haben, und wenn wir gewinnen würden oder wenn wir die Mehrheit hätten im Aufsichtsrat, dann wäre das unser neuer Präsident des e.V., unser neuer Vorstandsvorsitzender des e.V. Das ist jetzt passiert, das ist der Sebastian Kramer, der jetzt Präsident bei 96 e.V. wird und der hat sozusagen als seinen Plan gestützt von dem Carsten Linke, der im Vorfeld auch viel. Ich kann mir auch beileibe nicht vorstellen, dass nach diesem Ergebnis, was ja mehr als eindeutig war, dass die DFL das jetzt, ich sag mal, einfach so durchentscheidet. Es ist ja so gewesen, dass damals auch Herr Kind einmal eine Zeit lang diesen Antrag auf Aufnahmegenehmigung ruhend gestellt hat. Und das ist meine Vorstellung jetzt auch, dass der neue Vorstand gegenüber der DFL jetzt erst mal sagt, bitte behandelt diesen Antrag jetzt erst mal nicht weiter, stellt ihn ruhend. Wir möchten gerne Einsicht in die entsprechenden Unterlagen und Anträge haben, die möchten wir den Mitgliedern vorstellen. Dann werden wir eine ausordentliche Mitgliedersversammlung machen, darüber abstimmen und entweder man sagt dann, jawohl, kann so durchgehen, oder eben man sagt, wir nehmen diesen Antrag als e.V.
zurück.
Wie gesagt, drei Rechtsobjekte müssen diesen Antrag stellen. Ob das tatsächlich so einfach geht, das ist eine hochkomplexe juristische Frage. Da werden sich im Zweifel auch wieder Gerichte mit beschäftigen. Ob das insgesamt so gut ist für Hannover 96, ist wieder die nächste Frage. Aber dass Herr Kind es klaglos, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, hinnimmt, dass ihm der Antrag sozusagen wieder zurückgenommen wird, da kann man Zweifel daran haben. Also wie sich das dann weiterentwickelt, ist dann wirklich die nächste spannende Frage. Aber sozusagen die nächsten Schritte sind erst mal die, die ich eben gerade skizziert habe.
Okay, und das ist jetzt dasjenige, was den Antrag betrifft. Das habe ich soweit verstanden. Wahrscheinlich ist die DFBL auch gar nicht so unglücklich, wenn sie da jetzt nicht drüber entscheiden muss. Die ist da nämlich auch in einer interessanten Zwickmühle. Was jetzt aber ja darüber hinaus passieren wird, das hast du jetzt gerade schon angesprochen, ist, dass ja dann jetzt im e.V. aus dem Aufsichtsrat heraus dann eben ein neuer Präsident oder Vorsitzender des e.V. bestimmt wird, was er bisher Martin Kind war. Das heißt, er wird nicht mehr Präsident von Hannover 96 sein oder ist Präsident des Amtes, das man in der KGIAA hat? Ich bin da immer noch ein bisschen verwirrt.
Nein, also ich sage mal so, in der KGIAA ist man Geschäftsführer. Im e.V. ist man eigentlich, also der wirkliche Name ist Vorstandsvorsitzender, also der richtigen Begriff ist Vorstandsvorsitzender, aber umgangssprachlich der Präsident, der Vorstandsvorsitzende, der Präsident der Präsi, der regelt das sozusagen. Dass Herr Kind nicht mehr Präsident ist ab dieser Mitgliederversammlung, das hatte er allerdings vorher auch schon selbst angekündigt. Also er hat schon etwas längere Zeit gesagt, also ich stehe für das Präsidentenamt nicht mehr zur Verfügung, macht sinngemäß den Verein alleine, ich bleibe Geschäftsführer der KGIAA und habe da alle Fäden in der Hand, aber die Arbeit des e.V.-Präsidenten, die ich 20 Jahre gemacht habe, das möchte ich nicht mehr weitermachen. Und insoweit hatte das Team Kind auch als designierten Präsident, nämlich nicht Martin Kind, sondern eine andere Person, einen Herrn Hertha.
Okay, aber wenn es jetzt dann so ist, dass im e.V., der ja quasi in der Rangordnung zwischen e.V., GmbH und KGAA ganz oben steht, da jetzt die sogenannte Opposition jetzt dann auch den Vorsitzenden oder den Präsidenten stellt, müsste das dann nicht auch so mit so einem Trickle-down-Effekt bis runter in die KGAA landen, weil sie doch auch den Geschäftsführer bestimmen. Darum geht es ja im Kern.
Ja, da haben sich aber sowohl Carsten Linke, den ich jetzt mal im Moment als Sprecher dieser Kandidaten bezeichnen würde, weil er sich eben vielfach geäußert hat. Tatsächlich auch Sitzrat Vorsitzende, das ist Ralph Nestler geworden, das hat aber andere Gründe. Aber Herr Linke hatte sich eben sehr ausführlich dazu geäußert. Und er hat tatsächlich ausdrücklich gesagt und auch Sebastian Kammer, der neue Präsent, hat auch gesagt, wir werden in die KGAA nicht reinregieren. Also wir werden dieses Recht, was uns grundsätzlich zusteht, werden wir gar nicht nutzen. Weil, das muss man ja auch sagen, also auch ein großer Berg, der vor den neuen Verantwortlichen da steht, ist tatsächlich nicht nur sich darum zu kümmern, was mit diesem Antrag ist, sondern auch diesen, das muss man leider sagen, zerstrittenen Verein wieder zu einigen.
Also jetzt den Verein oder die zerstrittene Profi-Abteilung?
Ja, also es gibt Streit innerhalb des Vereins, wie gesagt, das muss man eben auch sagen, Respekt auch für alle anderen Kandidaten aus dem, in Anführungszeichen, Team Kind. Es gab auch 700 Leute, die eben da für Kandidaten gestimmt haben, also 1400 da, also der Abstand war schon sehr groß, aber immerhin 700 Mitglieder haben auch gesagt, der oder der oder der Kandidat des Team Kind wäre eine gute Wahl für den e.V. Also das zeigt ja, dass die Mitglieder in sich ja doch ein Stück weit auseinander dividiert sind. Also Streit innerhalb des Vereins und jetzt aber noch möglicher Streit mit der KGHA um die Frage, wer wird Geschäftsführer und können wir das wirklich bestimmt noch hin und her. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das das Ganze überfracht würde. Das heißt, der Ansatz, der da von den neuen Verantwortlichen gesetzt wird, nämlich sich jetzt nicht noch weiter mit Herrn Kind zu zerstreiten, das ist sicherlich ein ganz vernünftiger.
Weil man auch wirtschaftlich von ihm abhängig ist?
Ja, na klar, also der, ich sag mal so, die letzten Wintertransfers, die hat Herr Kind zwar finanziert, aber da hat er ein Darlehen gegeben, der KGHA. Er hätte theoretisch, ich kenne natürlich die Darlehensbedingungen nicht, aber ganz theoretisch natürlich die Möglichkeit, diese Darlehensbedingungen auch zurückzufordern. Dann hätte die KGH, also der Spielbetriebsveranstalter, keine Kohle mehr. Die kann Kohle gleich keine Spieler verpflichten, keine guten jedenfalls. Und dann wäre der sportliche Niedergang, der diese Saison nicht vielleicht ein Stück weit aus wirtschaftlichen, aber eher aus sportlichen Gründen ja im Moment zu dieser dramatischen Situation führt, der wäre bestimmt nicht aufzuhalten. Wie weit das dann gehen würde, ist eine ganz andere Frage, aber es wäre sicherlich für die sportlichen Ambitionen von Hannover 96 nicht förderlich, wenn da jetzt noch mehr Streit ist. Das heißt, eine große Aufgabe des Aufsichtsrats und des neuen Vorstandes wird es natürlich sein, diese Gesamtsituation möglichst so gut wie es eben geht zu befrieden. Man muss jetzt aufeinander zugehen, man muss versuchen, jetzt wieder irgendeine Art von Gemeinsamkeit zu entwickeln, das wäre sicherlich für Hannover 96 wünschenswert, ja absolut.
Aber ist das denn auch realistisch? Denn ich sehe jetzt quasi zwei Missionen oder zwei Aufgaben, die der Aufsichtsrat hatte. Punkt eins, man möchte verhindern, dass dieses Band, dieses Verbindnetzband zwischen e.V. und Profifußballabteilung, nämlich die Management GmbH und die Befugnisse, die man da hat, dass das gekappt wird. Das ist die eine Aufgabe. Und die andere Aufgabe ist, dass man damit gegen den Willen von Martin Kind handelt, der dieses Band unbedingt gekappt sehen wollte, damit er selbst die Macht habe. Und mit dem ist aber als zweite Aufgabe, muss man auch versuchen, den Verein als Gesamtes zu vereinen, um damit auch die Arbeit der Profifußballabteilung nicht zu gefährden. Und damit gehört er dann auch ein guter Umgang mit Martin Kind. Wie soll denn das eine erreicht werden, wenn man gleichzeitig auch das andere im Auge hat?
Das ist schwierig. Also ich habe da auch noch keine Patentlösung. Aber ich sage mal so, wenn mir jemand vor einem Jahr gesagt hätte, man hat überhaupt die Möglichkeit, das noch aufzuhalten und es lohnt sich dafür zu kämpfen, hätte ich wirklich auch Zweifel gehabt. Und das ist jetzt wieder so eine große Aufgabe. Aber dieses Gefühl, was sich aus dieser Mitgliederversammlung ergeben hat, dass man wirklich etwas erreichen kann, wenn man das vernünftig sachlich orientiert vorträgt, wenn man gute Konzepte hat, das hat wirklich viele Mitglieder und beileibe nicht nur Ultras oder sogenannten Traditionalisten oder als was immer man hier diskreditiert wurde, wenn man sich dafür eingesetzt hat. Das ist nicht nur von in Anzug und Zeichen denen getragen worden, sondern es war wirklich ein Querschnitt durch die gesamte Mitgliedschaft. Also da haben wirklich Konzepte überzeugt, da haben Personen überzeugt und mit diesem Pfund dieses großen Vorsprunges hat man vielleicht auch doch eine ganz gute Position. Und Herr Kind muss sich auf der anderen Seite überlegen, dass die Werthaltigkeit seines Invests, die er ja unzweifelhaft gemacht hat, wenn vielleicht auch nicht in dem Umfang, wie es die DFL gefordert hat, aber er hat ja nun tatsächlich investiert und auch Leistungen hier erbracht. Diesen Wert, dieses Invest, den würde er ja selbst auch beschädigen, wenn er das jetzt vollkommen trudeln lassen würde und sich beleidigt in die Schmollecke zurückziehen würde. Ich denke, dafür ist er wiederum vielleicht ein zu guter Geschäftsmann. Man muss aufeinander zugehen und es ist ja auch jahrelang von ihm auch propagiert worden. Also zwar dieses sogenannte Zwei-Säumen-Modell in Hannover, e.V. und Profibetrieb, aber unter einem Dach Hannover 96. Es gibt einen Grundlagenvertrag zwischen e.V. und KGRA, das Zusammenwirken und das Zusammenleben regelt. Das gegenseitige Rücksichtnahme ist da drin gefordert. Also man ist schon ein Stück weit darauf angewiesen, dass man miteinander auskommt. Und beide müssen eigentlich ein Interesse daran haben. Die wirklich spannende Frage, ob so die eigenen Befindlichkeiten dort über Bord geworfen werden und man sagt ja, man geht einen Schritt aufeinander zu, ohne dem, gebe ich dir recht, wird das schwierig, diese widerstreitenden Interessen irgendwie zusammenzubringen.
Also von Außenbetracht muss ich schon sagen, dass ich immer noch die handvolle Trümpfe bei Martin Kind sehe und das jetzt nur so ein kleiner Teilsieg ist. Also man bleibt irgendwie für die Kinder zusammen. Die Kinder ist jetzt halt einfach dann die Fußballabteilung von Hannover 96, die eben diejenige ist, die irgendwie sportlich Erfolg haben soll. Das wollen alle. Aber in letzter Konsequenz ist es, man sieht ja jetzt auch, das zeigt alle Zeiger deuten auf Richtung Zweite Liga und letztlich hängt es sich ja im Profifußball immer an wirtschaftlichen Fragen auf und solange man da in einer Abhängigkeit von Martin Kind ist und da sehe ich jetzt von außen zumindest keine Endlichkeit dieser Abhängigkeit, hat er doch eigentlich immer noch die Hand voller Trümpfe und das ist jetzt zwar ein schöner Zwischenerfolg mit dem Aufsichtsrat und vielleicht schafft man es ja sogar diesen Antrag irgendwie zurückzunehmen, ruhen zu lassen und so weiter und so fort, aber de facto geht an Martin Kind weiter kein Weg dran vorbei und er kann das dann auch ausspielen, also kann diese Hand dann eben ausspielen und kann dann das nächste Mal sagen, na dann hole ich jetzt halt im Winter keine Spieler und dann steigen wir vielleicht nicht auf in die 1. Liga, obwohl wir das eigentlich alle wollen.
Ja, das könnte so sein. Wie gesagt, die Gegenrede dazu ist, was ich gerade schon gesagt habe, er würde sich ja sein eigenes Investment dann kaputt machen. Dieses Wintereinkaufsbeispiel sozusagen, also wenn man dann die 10 Millionen doch nochmal investieren würde, um dann den Aufstieg zu schaffen und es dann im nächsten Jahr wirtschaftlich in der Bundesliga wieder viel besser läuft, dann ist das ja für ihn eine Investition, die er unter rein wirtschaftlichen Gesichtspunkten sehen muss.
Braucht er das denn so dringend, dass Hannover 96, also braucht er das denn, dass das Investment Hannover 96 jetzt schon funktioniert? So wie ich gehört habe, plant er ja auch das dann an die nächste Generation an seinen Sohn weiterzugeben. Kann er da nicht auch einen langen Atem haben und sagen, ich bin jetzt nicht über die Vermögensverhältnisse von Martin Kind informiert, aber ich würde mal vermuten, er kommt irgendwie über die Runden.
Ich denke, er kommt ganz gut über die Runden. Das ist aber auch relativ offen gewesen, wie es weitergeht, wenn er sich ganz zurückzieht. Das, was du sagst, er wollte seinen Sohn vererben, das war mal ein Gespräch. Es war auch mal ein Gespräch, das in eine Stiftung einzuführen. Es gab noch andere Ideen. Also ganz klar festgelegt, wie geht es eigentlich weiter, wenn Martin Kind als Person nicht mehr Gesellschafter ist. Das ist völlig offen und das war auch etwas, was ihn natürlich für einigermaßen unbeahrend gesorgt hat. Es gab sicherlich noch viele, die gesagt haben, wir trauen Martin Kind nichts Böses zu. Solange der da ist, wird das alles irgendwie vernünftig laufen. Nur was passiert denn, wenn er nicht mehr da ist? Und in dem Moment hast du tatsächlich null Einflussmöglichkeit. Also wenn er die vollständige Macht gehabt hätte, hätte er seine Anteile verkaufen können, ich sag mal, an wen auch immer. Und dann weißt du eben nicht mehr, ob das jemand ist, der dir wohlgesonnen ist, ob das jemand ist, der auf schnelles Geld aus ist, ob das jemand ist, der tatsächlich versucht, da Rendite zu erwirtschaften und nichts wieder reinvestiert, das war vollkommen offen. Und das war sicherlich auch unglücklich sozusagen, dass man das nicht verbindlicher kommuniziert hat. Aber noch mal auf deinen grundsätzlichen Einwand. Ja, klar hätte er die Möglichkeit, das verhungern zu lassen. Dann ist die Frage, was will man jetzt eigentlich? Ich kann nicht jetzt nur für mich persönlich, ich hänge nicht so unbedingt an der ersten Liga. Also wenn ich die Wahl hätte, ein Erstligaspiel zu sehen von einem Verein, wo ich null Mitspracherecht habe oder ein Zweitligaspiel zu sehen von einem Verein, wo ich als Mitglied noch versuchen kann, mitzugestalten. Wäre mir das Letztere immer lieber. Aber da gehen die Meinungen auch auseinander. Da gehen die Meinungen im Stadion auseinander, da gehen die Meinungen bei den Mitgliedern auseinander. Man muss eben realisieren, dass es auch einen großen Anteil von Leuten gibt, die sagen, nein, uns alles ist egal, wem das gehört, Hauptsache wir spielen Bundesliga. Muss man respektieren. Auf der anderen Seite sollte man aber auch die andere Seite, wie z.B. mich respektieren, sagt, darauf kommt es mir nicht so an. Und diese ganze 50 plus 1-Debatte, die immer, wenn deutsche Mannschaften kürzlich aus der Temps nicht ausschütteln, kein Wunder, England entfleuchtet uns, die haben alles viel mehr Geld, 50 plus 1 weg damit, wir brauchen neue Kohle. Das ist ein anderer Ansatz. Die Mitglieder in den letzten Verhandlungen haben diesen Ansatz nicht geteilt. Aber die haben gesagt, das wollen wir nicht so gerne.
Das wäre auch das, was mich interessieren würde. An Hannover 96 wird ja, wie an keinem anderen Verein, das Wohl und Wehe, das mit 50 plus 1 besteht, durchexerziert. Welche Signalwirkung hat denn deiner Meinung nach? Dieser kleine Teilerfolg, dass man über den Aufsichtsrat wieder als e.V. seine Mitbestimmung demonstrieren konnte?
Ich glaube, das hat eine ganz große bundesweite Signalwirkung. Ich glaube, das kann man gar nicht hoch genug einschätzen. Ich muss sagen, dass als Herr Kind seine Pläne vorgestellt hat, die Streitigkeiten hier waren, gab es ja eine wirklich große Solidarisierungswelle quer durch alle Ligen, quer durch alle Fanszenen, die sich das auch auf die Fahnen geschrieben haben, 50 plus 1 zu erhalten. Ich meine, da haben die Vereine, die Clubs, erste, zweite, dritte, vierte Liga schon gemerkt, das ist wirklich was, was unsere Fans, was unsere Mitglieder offensichtlich umtreibt. Also schon das, dass da so eine große Solidarität mit dem entsprechenden Kampf in Hannover festzustellen war. Ich denke schon, das hat ein Stück weit dafür gesorgt, dass man ein bisschen auf die Bremse getreten ist. Und wenn die Vereine jetzt sehen, wenn die Clubs jetzt sehen, ich kann die Leute nicht mehr mit dem Hoodie ruhig stellen und mit Versprechungen und ich kann, auch wenn ich Trikots verteile, das reicht vielleicht alles gar nicht mehr aus, um wirklich die Fans mitzunehmen. Und was passiert, wenn ich die Fans und Mitglieder nicht mitnehme? Dann habe ich solche Geisterspiele wie in Hannover während des Stimmungsboycots, dann habe ich ständig Streit, dann habe ich negative Presse. Das macht sich im Spiel bemerkbar, das macht sich bei der Mannschaft bemerkbar, das macht sich im ganzen Umfeld bemerkbar. Diese Unruhe ist sicherlich für den sportlichen Erfolg nicht förderlich. Ich denke mir, es hat sozusagen zwei Auswirkungen auf die Mitglieder und Fans, dass man eigentlich erkennen kann oder muss. Ja, wenn wir uns vernünftig organisieren, wenn wir das sachlich und vernünftig darbringen und wenn wir versuchen, Konzepte zu entwickeln, die seriös sind, dann kann man, wie das Beispiel Hannover zeigt, damit auch etwas erreichen. Und auf der anderen Seite die Clubs, die sehen, ui, wir können eben vielleicht doch nicht so wie in gut fairem Art, wie es der Präsident in Hannover gemacht hat, uns über alles hinwegsetzen und denken, wir kommen damit durch. Weil das hat das Beispiel Hannover gezeigt, das klappt nicht. Und insofern hat es sozusagen eine ganz große Auswirkung, eine ganz große Sprachwirkung. Das ist wirklich bundesweit wahrgenommen worden, es ist sehr reflektiert wahrgenommen worden, bundesweit reflektierter als in den lokalen Medien. Aber das ist natürlich bemerkt worden. Und wenn man noch einen Schritt weitergeht, dann muss man ja sagen, es hat ein netter Töterer gesagt, man nimmt sich Hüttl und die Gang den DFB vor. Am Ende des Tages ist der DFB auch ein Verein. Da kann nicht jeder hingehen und sagen, wir stimmen in der mittleren Versammlung ab, da sind da sechs Millionen und das geht natürlich nicht. Da gibt es Delegierte und. Und das ist natürlich mindestens genauso ein großer Klüngel und ein Konstrukt wie die Geschichte in Hannover. Aber am Ende des Tages wird da auch gewählt. Und wenn sich das sozusagen, wenn diese Strahlkraft, die jetzt dieses Ereignis in Hannover hatte, da auch in den einzelnen Sportvereinen durchsitzt, es gibt genug Kritikmöglichkeiten an Fernsehgelderverteilung, an dem Habitus des DFB und und und. Es gibt genug Kritik. Wenn sich die genauso organisieren würde, ich sag mal wie die Opposition in Hannover, dann kann sich der DFB wirklich warm anziehen. Das kannst du natürlich genauso machen. Das ist wirklich für die Fans, für die Mitglieder, für die Clubverantwortlichen, für den DFB. Die sollten alle wirklich ganz genau hingucken, was hier passiert ist.
Jetzt gerätst du aber richtig in Schwärmen, Andreas. Jetzt gerätst du aber richtig in Schwärmen. Wenn du mir jetzt gleich erklärst, dass wir so auch die FIFA reformiert bekommen und die Videobeweise abschaffen, dann kriegst du hier zwar alle Stimmen im Rasenfunk.
Das ist vielleicht ein Stück weit noch die Euphorie vom Samstag, aber das muss man auch wirklich nachvollziehen. Wenn ich diesen Weg über 2014, 2015, 2016 und was sich dann da entladen hat, als dieses Ergebnis bekommen hat, als dieses Ergebnis bekanntgegeben wurde. Also ich bin schon wirklich, wie gesagt, sehr lange fände ich, als bisher größtes Eigentum immer den Pokalsieg 92 wahrgenommen oder den Aufstieg 84, 85, als ich das erste Mal, ich persönlich sozusagen, in Anführungszeichen das erste Mal in der Bundesliga aufgestiegen bin. Das war alles auch großartig, ein sportlicher Erfolg und und und. Aber diese Situation Samstagabend, das ist dem in nichts nachgestanden. Wenn du gesehen hast, da lagen sich wirklich fremde Leute heulend in den Arm. Das war wirklich großartig.
Dann will ich dir die Euphorie auch nicht durch weitere kritische Nachfragen nehmen, sondern danke dir, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast. Das war Doktor Andreas Hüttl, der auch als Doktor-Hüttl mit U-E-Doppel-T und L bei Twitter ist. Andreas, danke dir, dass du uns das erklärt hast in einem Kurzpass. Ich hätte es nicht für Möglichkeiten, dass wir das in einen Kurzpass bekommen.
Vielen Dank, Max. Hat mir Spaß gemacht.
Auf bald. Ja, auf bald. Hoffentlich dann auch mit weiteren guten Nachrichten von Hannover 96. Die Strahlkraft hast du ja gerade schon sehr gut beschrieben. Und damit auch euch. Herzlichen Dank, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wie ihr alle wisst, haben wir auch schon mal einen anderen Kurzpass zur letzten Jahreshauptversammlung, Mitgliederversammlung, aufgenommen. Den werde ich natürlich nochmal verlinken. Und wir halten euch natürlich auf dem Laufenden, was bei Hannover 96 passiert. Und dann könnt ihr euch auf einen neuen Kurzpass freuen. Der kommt dann am Freitag.